hello what's up my name's samuel leeds
i'm with my beautiful friend darcy hello
and this property we are where are we
right now we are in winchester and is
winchester a cheap area to buy houses it
is not
this was voted was it the most or one of
the most expensive areas in britain it's
the most expensive area to buy property
right now in britain which is why you
didn't buy this house no
so basically this house is darcy she's
controlling it on a rent to rent so
you're renting this property on a
corporate letter yeah renting it out
you're 20 years old
darcy quit her job last year age 19 and
in this video we're going to give you a
tour of the house in winchester and
explain to you exactly what is what so
take us through the lounge darcy yeah of
course so if you follow me through here
this is our living room so you've got
the gorgeous couch there with a nice
piece of artwork to look at while you're
sat on the couch we've got a tv which
has netflix on a nice little fireplace
just for some lighting a nice
old-fashioned mirror if you want to take
a selfie or something before you go out
and a really good company as well you've
got a nice young man to chat with so
this is your boyfriend yes and um
honestly you've done really well because
this didn't look like this did it when
you first got it no when we first got it
just imagine a dump site in this room
and that's what it looked like what
literally what was it full of just full
of old furniture the old tenants who
were here left it in an utter state
ruined any piece of furniture that the
landlord had buy they left stuff like
clothes like old things everywhere
rotting it wasn't nice now when you told
the landlord that you wanted to rent
this presumably the landlord was happy
to rent it out to you because he was
renting in a terrible state yeah you've
done it up beautifully
but how did he feel about renting this
property to you knowing
that you weren't going to live in it
yourself you were then going to
basically rent it out on airbnb how did
he feel about that he was really happy
so originally i actually got this deal
through an agent right however the agent
that turned around to me and said we
can't do this because our legal team
won't allow it uh but the landlord still
wants to go ahead um so i then went
direct to landlord and actually did it
that way so
i did originally get it through an agent
now direct landlord and he was super
happy he is in business himself and he
would much rather work with a business
than with tenants especially like you
say his old tenants weren't good they
didn't leave in a good state and he's
overseas right so the landlord he's in
dubai in dubai
hands off doesn't want to deal with
anything yeah and you're giving him a
nice guy nice guy you're giving him a
guaranteed rent yes well you've been a
fabulous job and the location oh my
goodness it's you literally smack bang
in winchester
look at this
so this is the kitchen so you've got
your dining table with some fresh
flowers and then we've got a massive
kitchen with an island
not that the guest probably will do a
lot of cooking but if they want to then
the option's there
um when did you get the keys to the
property
on the
i think it's the 16th of october okay so
that's like two weeks ago yeah just just
over and you've literally made it look
like this in such a short amount of time
yes incredible thank you incredible well
really really good job and also as well
in terms of timing-wise
you want to get it done quickly because
if you're paying rent to the landlord
you want bookings to come in how are the
bookings coming in now it's finished
thick and fast
in
three days i got two and a half thousand
pounds worth of bookings in three days
well in two days that it was no yeah
which i was and is that continuing to
happen yep i'm still getting bookings
every day i've up to the price and i'm
still getting reservations so how much
rent are people prepared to pay
for one night in this house
uh average about 200 pounds a night
that's very good what about seasonal
kind of top end yep so top end you find
the other airbnb's in area go for about
500 pounds a night so i think the max i
would do this for was probably 350 or
400 um on you know such times as new
years height of summer graduation time
because there's a massive university
here um so yeah people christmas markets
yep which is all happening yes it's all
happening the most it's the biggest one
in the whole of hampshire the winchester
market it's massive draws loads of
attention from all over
um which is why they love my property
because the market is just behind right
excellent we'll take some stairs
and this is the first bedroom i actually
got the landlord to pay to get all the
carpets up here re-done
because the tenants left stains and
stuff on them
nice you know typical wooden bed white
sheets egyptian cotton towels
you know just fine clean things for our
guests
keeping rose gold themes throughout with
the lamps um you've done it really well
thank you so so if the landlord had to
pay for some stuff like you've got the
large pay for the carpets
what you had to pay for
the furniture right and you've gone
looks like you've been quite high-end
yes i mean this is just fabulous i mean
there's these kind of things you don't
get from a charity shop you know it
costs it costs decent money
um how much how much how much this sort
of stuff cost like
wardrobe how much you're talking uh i
again got this off a facebook
marketplace okay great it's my favorite
little thing um i think i've got two of
these actually i only put one of them in
here
i think it was a hundred pounds for the
two
which is amazing they're massive
wardrobes really good spec
um i got that um
all of this stuff is normally from ikea
but i got that for only 20 pounds how
about all this i mean this looks nice
that was about 20 pounds as well i guess
he did you know i didn't
shop and what about the bed how much are
you talking for the whole bed bedding um
so the bed was i believe 125 pounds i
did buy that new the mattress was about
a hundred pounds which is actually super
cheap for a mattress
it's a comfy you need it to be because
the last thing you want is you're
getting complaints from guests exactly
the most expensive thing for me is the
linen because i buy from a company
called richard hamworth who like supply
like all the hotels
um and the
towels are really expensive because i do
buy them new their egyptian cotton
because you know
it just makes it just it just says
quality though doesn't it yes what about
the paint did you paint this yourself
yeah bought some paint from b and q put
the music on painted all the walls how
much does that cost well again 30 pounds
for you
but did it ourselves so you've kind of
done it really high end but at the same
time without spending a fortune yeah
exactly being extra this is nice
the balcony you can literally see the
winchester cathedral yes um there's all
the the market is literally you step out
and you're there you're in the hustle
and bustle of the market and the high
street and i came from buckinghamshire
beckons field today which is a beautiful
very posh area but when i got out the
car here i was like wow like this i
wanted to speak different you know
how do you do dart it's very it just
feels so quiet and beautiful um so i can
see why people would pay two three
hundred pounds on how to be yeah um so
generally speaking then i mean what kind
of what percentage are you thinking
what occupancy
how full do you reckon it's going to be
so i believe the average of winchester
is about 80
it's very very high here it's very
popular area all year round because in
the winter there's always something
going on and then in the summer there's
always something going on yeah so yeah
i'd say average about 80. um and this is
smack bang in it this is the most
central
airbnb
out of all of them there isn't one more
sensor so 80 is conservative you've got
a balcony yeah big island in the island
kitchen okay so how much are you
thinking you're going to be able to
turn around what total cash will you
bring in obviously you've got a lot of
expenses like the landlord for a start
but how much cash are you expecting to
bring in per month on average so with
the average occupancy of around i've
calculated with 75 it will average about
2 000 profit and then obviously if
that's you know 90 100 you're talking
three plus thousand pounds a month in
profit wow
three grand a month profit yep
that's ridiculous yeah that's an average
salary yes for a 35 year old man yes and
you're a 20 year old yeah and this one
property you're expected to make about
three grand of profit yeah how much are
you paying the landlord for this
1550 pounds you're such a good
negotiator
such a good negotiator how much you pay
for this um that already actually came
okay which was a real real bonus so did
the bed similar oh the bed came the bed
and the wardrobe came with the property
that was the only thing things from the
last perspective it sounds really cheap
one thousand five hundred and fifty
pounds what you said yes because we're
looking at it like this yeah putting it
on airbnb some people might think why
doesn't the landlord just put it on
airbnb it's not about putting it on
airbnb
you need to know what you do it's a
business yeah it is it has to run
smoothly you have to have amazing
cleaners and the power team you have to
make sure you're giving the clients
everything that they want so yeah it's
much systemize it yeah i know so many
landlords that have said oh i'm just
going to try and do it myself and then
three months later they go actually have
it back yeah because it's actually a
skill and you've paid to be educated
you're part of the academy the e-academy
and you've gone through the service
combination intensive how was it by the
way best one of the training really yeah
my
favorite well it's it's you've made your
money back up now so yes exactly exactly
it was worth it and this isn't your
first property right no this is my
second one now when did you quit your
job in may right got my first essay in
june and then secured this one in
september right amazing and how did your
first property come about
um
just at your event actually which was
really funny i was at an event of
samuels and they were getting us to call
agents
i called them with the script got the
viewing and that viewing turned into my
first ever deal and how's that going
really good how much profit is that
making each month so
our good month this year made a thousand
pounds but on average let's say about
700
which is quite a small two bed flat
which is very good where is that
it's in portsmouth near gunwolf keys so
you've got an apartment in portsmouth a
house in winchester what's next
um well i want to get five rent to rent
um and then after that i want to go into
development property development well
you know you know to call when that i
know
exactly so good
ben you must be uh you must be really
proud of what darcy's done as well
done incredible right these were the
bookings in two days
oh wow
so the calendar is just filling up yeah
you put it on just two days ago yes
it was crazy massive congrats well i
want to say credit where credit's due
massive congratulations check out darcy
i'll leave her instagram only if you're
early yeah that's fine
check out darcy i'll leave her instagram
in the description so hit her up also my
mum ben big respect brother you know
what i also have to say respect for
supporting darcy in this because i think
it's so much easier i know you've been
painting and doing everything and it
just it's so much easier when you've got
a supportive partner on board yeah it
makes all the difference like when you
come here 8 a.m and you're here till 10
p.m just
tidying it it's nice to have someone
yeah what would be your biggest piece of
advice to someone that's really inspired
by your story that's thinking i want to
do the same thing what would your words
of advice be
just take action stop making excuses
because at the end of the day you're
probably not in a bad position compared
to other people in the world so just get
on with it yeah and you started no one
gave you money to get started no you
didn't you weren't born with a silver
spoon in winchester
no i was not i actually don't live in
winter i do not live in the
richest or most expensive town what did
your friends family parents think when
you said at 19 years old i've just been
on samuel lee's course i've just spent a
lot of money on the training and now
i've quit my job they thought i was
going mad
seriously thought i was mental couldn't
believe what i was doing
um had a few strong words with them but
now they're oh now they are all for it
of course because the money's coming oh
yeah now that i i get it
but no you know what i'm just so pleased
to see so if you want to do the same
thing that darcy did then why don't you
come and join us at the renter
revolution come to a free training
program i'll leave a link in the
description you can do the same thing
too you've done incredible i mean
honestly super proud don't forget to
subscribe to the channel also hit the
like button drop a nice comment and
we'll see you next time peace